all right joining us now president Trump
speaking tonight at a Unity rally here
in New Hampshire we'll dip back in in a
few minutes joining us now on set Fox
News contributor Charlie hert the
co-host of two hit shows the five in
America's Newsroom and I will be her
guest tomorrow which is a great honor M
i' got the countdown clock what do you
make of where we are now because it's
interesting because you know we were
here in this very place in 2016 and 2020
and in uh 16 when we came here there
were still I think eight candidates left
and it was at the New Hampshire debate
where you had what what was called the
murder suicide of Marco Rubio between
strategize between Trump and Chris
Christie and just to think of how much
history is behind us in those eight
years very tumultuous to get to a point
where you are in a two-person race Nikki
Haley has said all along that that's
what she wanted and she did help winow
the field right she is still in it she's
here for tomorrow uh in New Hampshire
the polls are not great for her
and I don't know if she got to the two
person race too late um but you see what
Donald Trump there bringing in Doug
bergham and V ramaswami Tim Scott all
previous opponents of his in this
primary and they're all for him
screaming four more years and Tim Scott
is from South Carolina which would be up
next at well at Nevada in South Carolina
uh what do you make of this Charlie well
uh certainly Nikki Haley got what she
wanted as you say maybe a little bit
late but now it's want exactly now it's
G to she's going to get her one-on-one
race um I I still think that you know
it's it's um I'm I'm a little cautious
just because when you're looking at 40%
of the PO the voting population here who
is independent and they have the choice
tomorrow of uh going in and writing in
uh Joe Biden's name or playing in the
Republican primary and trying to uh hurt
Trump and help Nikki Haley I think you
know it's it's too soon to say for
certain but if Donald Trump wins by you
know 40 points or wins by two points
it's the difference between it's a slow
death or a fast death it's it's I I
don't see it the trajectory is not going
to change after well the number of
people that switched it was I think the
Secretary of State's office said about
4,000 3,000 yeah uh and that ended in
October however you do have this large
number of Independents they can vote in
either the Republican or Democratic
primary or not vote at all um and there
have been efforts organized efforts to
get people to vote for Nikki Haley to
extend out what they think will be it
will force Donald Trump to spend more
money extend the the primary as long as
possible therefore that benefits them in
the long run it's an interesting
strategy I don't think it'll really work
and Nikki Haley has rejected that saying
I'm not trying to do that if people want
to vote for me she's never going to turn
them away that's what she says but I
also think it's interesting there's 40%
independent here in Nevada in New
Hampshire excuse me we have not in
Nevada yet um but in the country did you
see the recent Gallop poll 43 3% of the
country says that they are independent
so the both parties are the largest
number ever right it's the largest
number so both parties are shrinking and
so I'm really interested going forward
let's say that President Trump thrs up
the nomination how did you go back to an
Obama Trump Biden voter and say give me
another shot that will be interesting
messaging and and you will need to get
some of those people if he's going to
win the general James carille said and I
pay attention when James speaks I've
I've had a number of debate with debates
with him over the years fun guy crazy
but fun but smart also very and one of
the things he said is a third party
independent run this year is going to
get a hell of a lot of votes and I think
he's right uh but I also don't think
that that's going to hurt Donald Trump I
think that that hurts Joe Biden and if
it's no labels if it's RFK I think and
even if it's a never Trumper type person
who wants to run uh and think that
they're going to be a spoiler for Donald
Trump I don't think it's going to work I
Joe mansion and tulsey gabard I think I
I think it hurt I think it all hurts Joe
Biden I think that you know any
alternative you Donald as you know Sean
Donald Trump's supporters are not like
wavering and the one thing that that was
absolutely declared in Iowa and is true
in all of these polls is you know the
question for me was have Republicans
grown exhausted and do they want to move
on they don't want to move on they want
to stay and they want to fight and they
want to fight with this guy and and and
to me you know desantis's decision to
get out and and his comments I thought
were so interesting to me that was the
most interesting part was the part where
he his analysis that look I did my best
people want to stick with the guy that
brought him this far and they want to
fight and I think it's true I lik it in
National Review there was a headline by
Philip Klein that said that DeSantis was
like pelaton in a postco world right
it's like you don't actually need you
yet right now actually we're pretty good
with what we had before so oh that's
that's a pretty good analogy all right
who would be the people in four years
from now when we're here God willing
again four years from now well I thought
it was very interesting that um behind
the scenes what DeSantis was saying and
his people were saying is that as he
went around meeting voters they might
say to him you're our guy in 2028 if
Trump weren't running we'd be with you
but we're going to stick with him now
you you don't disagree he is a young
leading conservative America first voice
in the country I 100% And he's an
extremely competent executive but he's
not a great campaigner and can he can he
become a great campaigner or is that
instinctual I think that's an
interesting question I mean I was not
that critical of his campaign as others
have been um I'll tell you I learned a
lot about him the night he debated Nome
oh yeah I bet because he came in
prepared and he there was nothing phased
him you know came in with you know every
pre prepared line ready you know to fire
out every bullet he had in his political
gun he's brilliant as running as an
incumbent as we saw in 2022 uh he had
accomplishments to run on and people
loved him he beat uh Charlie Chris by by
over 20 points in a swing state of
Florida which is no longer a swing state
and so to me the question is does he end
up running in 2028 sort of as an
incumbent and the way only way I see
that is if Donald Trump decides to pick
him as vice president and I know it seem
everything seems kind of acrimonious
right now but I don't think it's out of
the question I think that you know if
Donald Trump decides that that Ronda in
that sense he would be anointing him his
successor exactly because as Dana before
we came on the air rightly pointed out
if somebody the the day after election
day whoever that vice president is
they're probably going to have a eye on
that desk that Donald Trump has with a
red button that's not for nuclear
weapons but for diet
that's right that's what is and they
better have a better political operation
than KLA Harris well said that's true uh
great to see you I'll see you on your
show can't wait uh Charlie good to see
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else